đưa người ăn tích ra 2 in kilomét, yếu nhau có nặng bún năm vừa gặp mặt đã làm lễ sạm ngón.
Mới đây, đặt video bún năm yêu ra lên đô gặp mặt của cập loại trẻ ở năm đàn,
người ăn được lên chuyên đen trọng trên các mạng xá hội, với những trình cải trải chiều.
Chó khi một số người chúc phúc cho đối trẻ, lại có nhiều người phán sát về từ nhiều có mạng của cập loại.
Y tại miết, nãy xác của cập mặt lên đô này không ngåt tôn.
Cập đối đã tự chức sạm ngó trước khi chỗ lại cụ việc gần hai đời khác nhau, một ở nệt bản,
một ở đây luôn chú bốc, nhưng vẫn nằm chỉ cho video cho biết.
Đạn video được quay vào ngày 1 xáu tăng chiến tại xanh bay của tế đủc bài,
những cách đây và ngày, anh mới ăn tải lên mạng xá hội.
Đó là người đều tiến pháp và bạn gái mựng tiện tiền, cập mặt xàu bún năm yêu cơ mạng.
Thác và anh tiền đều diễn năm anh nhìn không chặp lịch bột, quay ở năm đàn.
Y an, hai gia đình cách nhau khoảng 15 phút di sẽ máy.
Được biết, cập đối đã làm lễ sạm ngó và dự định tổ chức đặc gửi phó năm sau.
Hôm mình chính thẳng, cả hai đã đáp mai bay người xanh nghiệp người xanh đại loàn,
quay trở lại với công việc của mình.
Lúc trai ai cũng tỏ ra bình thường, nhưng trên đường ra xanh bay, ai cũng khóc sức mất.